I think it’s important for entrepreneurs
to thank the people in their lives
who are helping make an impact
who are helping them grow their business
because it’s hard doing everything yourself.
So today I want to thank Dan Weiniger
and Dan is a… (how did I meet Dan?)
Dan – I met through Facebook.
And he’s was fan of my stuff
and liked the content that I was creating
and one day, you know, he reached out to me
and asked me to check out his video
and if I had any feedback for him.
And I gave him some thoughts
and told him a few ways to improve it
and he took that and went right to work
and started making them better.
And he kept being a fan
he kept looking at the content I was putting out
and said, “Evan, I’d like you to come
and potentially speak at our company’s event
our annual retreat”
for all the franchisees that he’s a part of.
And he connected me with the founder
and we had a great session
and then he invited me to come down
and I just came back from Orlando
and I met Dan, I met the team
and it was a great experience.
And what I love about Dan
is that he’s constantly trying to reach out to people
to find out how he can help them.
He’s not just selling his services, right
he’s not contacting me and saying, “Hey Evan
will you buy my video services?” right.
He’s looking for ways to help.
So he started just by being a fan
and sharing some of my stuff
and of course, that helps me, right
and if he’s telling me that he likes some of the stuff I’m creating
and which one it is, that helps me gauge, you know
what’s working and what isn’t
and it make me feel good too to hear from fans.
And then he’s looking for ways
that he can help his fellow franchisees, right.
So he loved the content I was creating
the videos I was putting out
and thought that other people could benefit from it as well
and beyond just sharing the links of the videos
to have me come and speak at their event
and connect with people one on one.
And he did that because he genuinely wanted
his other franchisees to be better.
And Dan makes a habit of trying to connect people
even if it has nothing to do with his business
just trying to connect people because he realizes
first that it makes him feel good
right, it makes the other person feel good
and then it also helps your business.
If you’re spending your time helping people
you’re going to stay top of mind
and they’re going to look for ways
to help you out as well.
So Dan, thank you so much.
Thank you for being a fan
thank you for being a friend
thank you for picking me up from the airport
thank you for recommending me to the event.
I had a blast meeting you.
And for those of you watching
I hope you’ll take some time this week to thank somebody
who’s had an impact in your business somehow
and make them feel special.
Believe.
For those of you watching
you liked the video
consider supporting me by clicking the link in the description.
Leave a comment.
Let me know what you think
and click on my face to subscribe to the channel.
Thank you so much, I’ll see you soon.